what have you learned
running a company that was different you
know in 2010 versus today well i mean
how old were you i mean how old are you
now are you 40.
i'm 39. you're 39 so when you were on
the program last you were 29
yeah you started the company when you
were 24 or 25 so it's basically
squarespace is basically your entire
professional career
yeah you learned a lot and you kept the
ceo slot right i mean a lot of times
people would in a growing business maybe
they say professional management did
they ever try to push you to uh put in
professional management
no i think for the past decade that
that's really not been something we've
talked about i think you know it's
something i consider you know like in
terms of like do i like what i'm doing
you know every single day you ask you
know what's changed in 10 years i mean
we're 1500 people today acro and we've
you know done acquisitions we're across
so many different product lines we're
public you know we have different
constituents i mean that is a totally
different thing than you know
10 years ago we had just
we had just done our first outside round
with index and excel
and you know we were like a year into
that and totally different kind of
management team totally different
employee i mean how many plays we have
back then
i had like 50 60 when we talked so yeah
much smaller so yeah i mean you know you
talk to a lot of um
startup founders and ceos i mean the job
of uh you know what you're doing in 1500
person company is completely different
than what you're doing at 60. i mean you
know before we got on you were talking
about you know i was on cnbc yesterday
talking about some new product releases
we had and we got all these investor
meetings now you know external you know
all the all the public side of things so
talking to analysts um
so yeah it's totally different
talk about management teams over time
because we all know when you start a
company you're bootstrapping it maybe
you got a little bit of money let's face
it you can't pay the salaries that
people who work at giant publicly traded
companies can or you know salaries that
people like google or facebook at scale
get paid so you basically grab your
friends or you hire from within and then
over time they say hey you got to get
professional management hey you got to
get someone who's done this before and
obviously somebody who's been the cfo of
a public company is not coming to work
at you know 10 50 person squarespace
and they shouldn't right because they're
not they're gonna get bored right i mean
everything they're used to in terms of
infrastructure i mean a cfo of a public
company coming to 20 person squarespace
the finance team
publicly traded companies probably
multiple times the size that they have
no infrastructure things right people
forget
sometimes things move very fast in a
startup but
actually they kind of move really slow
sometimes too i mean you've only got a
couple engineers yeah you can iterate
faster because you don't have you know
all this all these eyes on you and you
know you know deploying a product that
you know is relied on by millions like
what we have is very different than you
know
there's tens of thousands of customers
and we're just quickly updating we can
roll back in a second it's not you know
a million yeah it's a different it's a
different thing but yeah i mean look
it's the hardest part of it right that
the people who have all that experience
the big managers who manage managers and
all that it doesn't it doesn't apply
when you're 20 30 40 people and um it's
just a different skill set and so what
about when you get into that middle
stage or a tweeter now you got a couple
100 people it's pretty clear you have
product market fit it's scaling every
year during those years you're probably
doubling your revenue year over year
tripling your revenue you're growing 10
20 month over month and now you got to
make that decision okay i got somebody
who's in this position
who's grown with the company but man
they're in over their head they've never
done this before
and they're telling me hey i got to
bring in some more senior people how did
you manage that whole transitional and
evolutional period because i know i hear
from the boards i'm on and founders yeah
could be kind of the hardest thing yeah
i just go ahead and say like i don't
know poorly like you look back at that
not that poorly because i'm here but i
mean yeah i look back and i'm like that
thing that took three years should have
taken one what was i doing and all that
i think
i'll say
i'll say two things during that time one
is
a lot of the time when
the person's not working out in the role
they end up failing their peers as much
as they end up failing you
and there's a bit of a
a situation there and i'm not talking
like people just can't get along i'm
talking like they're not delivering for
one another they're not showing up right
so the one team can't plan because the
other team's just not doing the work and
so that's one source of like sort of hey
i gotta have a conversation here you
you're not working with you're not
giving them what they need or they're
failing their teams
and then the other then the other thing
that so that's bottom up and then
there's people you know who are on the
team side by side yeah and then and then
the final direction which was which was
kind of tough for me
is they actually have to show up to me
differently
because i you know you can't like i
don't know you're one-on-one's a long
time yeah when it's small they're not
like they're not so formal right they're
not just showing up with the deck and
here's this and here's what i've
delivered i almost feel like when it
gets bigger you know my department
reviews with my execs it's almost like
the board meeting and i'm the board and
they're showing up and presenting stuff
and this is their time and we're
checking in and i want to know how
they're running things what i can you
know unblock for them and
for a lot of people when it's smaller it
just feels weird to start to show up to
me in a much more formal way and unless
they do i'm done because i can't i i
just can't i just can't run it any other
way
yeah when you get to a certain scale the
stakes have gone up and you know if you
look at it like the difference between
playing basketball you know pick up
basketball in the park you know you turn
the ball over whatever you know you
don't play defense who cares it's a game
in the park but now you're the knicks
you're in the playoffs you know when you
see some player is not hitting their
free throws the other team members are
going to go to the coach and say hey we
can't have this person in the game or at
least not in this role as a starter
maybe they can come off the bench and do
other things here but they can't be
you know on the floor in the final 10
minutes yeah and then i'm going to get
pissed because we're a sponsor at index
we're all in the jersey and i'm going to
we're going to pull out let's go
you guys
this is actually a very interesting
thing i think that you also
um were
not only first on the logos on jerseys
because that was a big deal people
forgot that when the knicks and a couple
of teams tested that that was a first
for the nba there was big controversy
about it oh my god we're gonna put a
logo on the thing yeah you are also
first to podcasting
we were very very early i mean you were
one of our first five i think one of our
first is bing yourself mailchimp
um
a walker law we had like four or five
sponsors in the first year or two that
were just incredibly supportive yeah
yeah i mean we've been doing that for
over ten
oh that's gotta be ten years yeah it's
at least twelve maybe a little bit more
but i mean it's always been a huge
great medium for us go ahead well i was
gonna say what what was it about
podcasting and the knicks jerseys and
these kind of things that you saw early
as a marketer when at those times
everybody was saying you know buy google
ads buy facebook ads well we do that
stuff too right i mean so i i would
never you know do branded the exclusion
of direct response that's working um
and you know also i might mention i
think we're at our seventh eighth super
bowl out now i mean that's that's a lot
um and when we were doing those a while
ago
uh
you know we were in an interesting
context there um you know it was a lot
of car companies and carbs and alcohol
and you know and then there's like
websites it's like really um but it you
know it worked for us i think in to
answer the original question though
regarding podcasts so
back then
it was much more of the wild west and
what was great about it is you had these
really great show creators who had a
great connection with their audience and
for us to be able to go to somebody and
and educate them on the product and say
look it's marked as an ad of course you
know
all of our ads are marked as ads but we
want to support you and if you really
like the product talk about it and
people do an ad read and it'd be
authentic and that would work with their
audience and they put a coupon code in
the in the in the podcast and
they tell their listeners hey uh you
know squarespace's reporting show uses
coupon if you need a website blah blah
blah and it gave us great attribution um
it gave us great reach right because
podcasts would listen to an all you know
if we're doing an english podcast you
know non-english markets as well so it
gave us global reach and you know back
before people would swap the ads out
the ad would just play forever oh that's
right i mean certainly we hard code them
into ours so whatever ads you did
forever they're just there forever and
that was always my philosophy on it
this week in startups is brought to you
by silicon valley bank what's next what
if are we ready now what these are the
questions that can keep founders up at
night and no one understands this quite
like silicon valley bank for over 35
years silicon valley bank has helped
thousands of high growth companies by
providing scalable financial solutions
along with insights and expertise that
many other banks just can't from
healthcare to hardware software to
infrastructure sbb works with companies
across the innovation landscape at all
stages of the journey anticipating their
needs even before they do and by
providing access to insights and
in-depth reports svb can help you make
more informed decisions and assist in
turning your great idea into a great
business
which could be why fifty percent of
us-based venture-backed tech and life
science companies bank with svb
learn more at svb.com
twist silicon valley bank built for
what's next